y lo peor pasó pero las autoridades
insisten en que el peligro persiste tras
tocar tierra como huracán de fuerza 4 en
el sur de luisiana ahí va se degradó a
tormenta tropical este lunes por la
mañana en nueva orleans empiezan a
evaluar el rastro que dejó anoche el
temporal
que hay que limpiar las calles y
restablecer la electricidad quién sabe
cuánto puede tardar que el transporte
público y los coches vuelvan a circular
ahora todos son vehículos de policía y
de emergencia
ahí te dejo la mayoría de luisiana sin
electricidad destruyó varios edificios y
causó inundaciones que dejaron atrapadas
a decenas de personas sin embargo en
nueva orleans los vecinos consideran que
no fue equiparable al paso del katrina
16 años atrás lagüens
fueron vientos muy fuertes
afortunadamente no tantas inundaciones
esta es la principal diferencia entre
esta tormenta y katrina en esta hubo
muchos daños causados por el viento y en
katrina más por las inundaciones con
katrina tuvimos más de medio metro de
agua durante dos semanas week el chef el
presidente de eeuu prometió una
respuesta distinta a la que dio en ese
momento la administración bush un
abandono institucional que agravó las
consecuencias de la catástrofe natural
by dénia decretó el estado de emergencia
en luisiana y misisipí y estableció un
plan de choque para la población
afectada aunque la intensidad haya
disminuido las autoridades alertan que
las lluvias y los vientos pueden seguir
causando daños en el camino de la
borrasca hacia el noreste del país